بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف المرسلين
اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد
رئيس مجلس الوزراء في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيق
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده الساده والسيدات
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
اود بدايه التوجه بالشكر الجزيل الى خادم
الحرمين الشريفين جلاله الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز والى ولي عهده رئيس مجلس
الوزراء سمو الامير الملكي محمد بن سلمان
والى الشعب السعودي عموما
على استضافه هذه الدوره الثانيه والثلاثين
الاجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه وعلى
ما احطنا به من حفاوه استقبال وكرم ضيافه
منذ وصولنا لهذه الارض الطيبه المباركه
ولا يسعني في هذا المقام الى ان انوه ايضا
بالجهود الدؤوب التي يبلغها سعاده الامير
العام السيد احمد ابو الغيط وفريقه في
سبيل تطوير عمل جامعتنا العربيه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم
ايها الساده والسيدات انما يلوح في خضن
الازمات المتنوعه التي تجتاح العالم من
بوادر تغيرات جيوستراتيجي عميقه
ليؤكدنا لا يؤكد حاجتنا الماسه الى راس
الصفوف يتجاوز الخلافات لتطوير وترقيه
عملنا العربي المشترك
فبقدر ما يتعزز هذا العمل تتحسن قدرتنا
الجماعيه على الصمود في وجه مختلف
التحديات وكذلك فعاليه جهودنا في تحقيق ما
نطمح اليه من التنميه ومن استقرار
ثم ان عملنا المشترك هو الذي به يقوى
ويتعزز حضورنا على الساحات على الساحه على
الساحات الدوليه سياسيا واقتصاديا وبيئيا
وثقافيا
واود في هذا الاطار انا اجدد رقمنا للجهود
التي تبرها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه لاستضافه
في دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده على
استضافه الدوره القادمه لمؤتمر اطراف
اتفاقيه الامم المتحده الايطاليه بشان
طاير المناخ اصحاب الجلال والفخامه ايها
الساده والسيده ان احساسي بضروره تطوير
عملا العربي المشترك يزداد عمقا وقوه كلما
نظرت الى الوضع الراهن في
فلسطين والى ما يشهده عالمنا العربي من
نزاعات وما يواجه من تحديات مصيريه واننا
في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الموريتانيه
لنودين بقوه الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه ونجدد
التاكيد علامات على تمسكنا بحق
الفلسطينيين في اقامه دوله مستقله عاصمتها
القدس الشرقيه وفقا لما تقتضي به قرارات
الامم المتحده ذات الصله ومبادره السلام
العربي
ونؤكد كذلك تمسكنا بالحلول التي تحفظ
الوحده الترابيه وترسيد عائمه الاستقرار
والامن في كل من ليبيا واليمن مستبشرين
بما يلوح من الفراش في البلدين كما ندعو
في ذات الوقت الى بدر كل الجهود الممكنه
لوقف الاعمال القتاليه بشكل دائم وفعال في
جمهوريه السودان ولخلق ظروف المناسبه
لتقديم الدعم الانساني وللتاسيس لحل سياسي
شامل في هذا البلد الشقيق
وانني لا اشيده هنا بكل الجهود العربيه
المبذوله في هذا الصدد وخاصه بالرعايه
السعوديه الكريمه للمحادثات بين الاطراف
السودانيه الشقيقه
عاملا ان يفضي الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل
اليه الى رسم خارطه طريق تضمن وحده
السودان والسلامه اراضيه وحق مواطنيه في
الامن والاستقرار
واشيد كذلك بعوده جمهوريه سوريا الشقيقه
للحضن للحضن العربي املا لها ان تستعيذ
بشكل كامل
دورها المحوري التاريخيه في تعزيز العمل
العربي المشترك ومرحبا باخي صاحب الفخامه
الرئيس بشار الاسد بين اشقائه اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسموم ايها الساده
والسيدات
ان العماله العربيه المشترك لا يقوى الا
بقدر قوه الشراكات الاقتصاديه بين بلداننا
العربيه ولذا لابد لنا من تعزيز تبادلاتنا
الاقتصاديه البينيه تمهيدا لقيام سوق
عربيه مشترك تؤسس لتنميه المستديمه وشامله
في فضائلنا العربي ومن هذا المنطلق
تنبعل اهميه القصوى التي توليها بلادنا
لانعقاد الدوره الخامسه للقمه العربيه
التنمويه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في
نواكشوط مطلع شهر نوفمبر القادم والتي
يحدون الامل في ان تكون محطه متميزه من
مسيره العمل العربي المشترك وانني ارجل
لاعمال هذه الدوره الثانيه والثلاثين
الاجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه كل
النجاح والتوفيق لا اعبر لكم مسبقا اخوتي
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسموم السرور
باستقبالكم في نواكشوط لمشاركه فعاليات
القمه العربيه التنمويه في دورتها الخامسه
اشكركم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات